I'll have to work on myself to be able
to trust again
but I can do that I'm tough old broad I
really am whatever I'm just going back
like yes I can I know that's right
Debbie encourage yourself I'm ready to
rock and roll
Miss Debbie packs up to leave Morocco
and head back to the states after
accusing Usama of using her just to get
a green card and she makes it clear now
that she's woken up from this fantasy
she doesn't plan on talking to him ever
again but I'm not gonna let the bad guy
win
Osama don't win in this Debbie's gonna
win in this
[Applause]
[Music]
this episode let's talk about it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melissia I'm
not gonna waste any time let's get into
Debbie officially leaving Usama and not
just leaving him is how she did it if
you love Debbie you're going to love her
even more after this episode and if you
can care less about the lady you should
at least get a good laugh or smiling
alright last episode Debbie told Usama
they are parting ways after he called
her crazy sick mentally ill and
basically admitted that his main
intention with her is to get a green
card and move to the U.S now this
episode picks up the day after their
fight Usama reaches out to Debbie and
asks to meet face to face
[Music]
okay work it Miss Debbie
she is shredding with this little dress
on once she gets in the car headed to
meet with Usama she opens up about a
pattern she's seeing in him he'll do
wrong and get angry and act like some
stranger but then he knows how to
apologize he's like a professional at
apologies yeah I've come across that
before it's like they're playing
peek-a-boo they show you who they are
then they feel bad about it so they try
to hide again behind an apology no learn
how to control yourself so you don't
have to say sorry all the time
Debbie arrives to the cafe before Usama
and gets settled
for a drink do you have any Texas
margarita
now look at the waiter's face
he asked for a Texas margarita in
Morocco
basically Miss Debbie was saying give me
the strongest thing you have but this
Cafe only has tea and coffee it's a
desert for margaritas out here which in
my opinion might be best for the
conversation that Debbie is about to
have once Usama arrives he tells the
camera he doesn't love Debbie just to
get a visa to the U.S he loves her
because of her passion for art and
because she understands him he then
attempts to apologize to Debbie I told
you this before that's when I am I'm
giving you don't have to care about what
I'm saying
just gave me the space and time and
after I can check
I mean I am hungry I don't even focus or
think of what I'm saying
well Usama that's something to work on
sweetheart instead of putting the
responsibility on others by telling them
to move around it you're a grown man you
know my dad always tell me this when
you're angry Sometimes the best thing
you can do is
be quiet don't say anything at all
because in most cases when you speak out
of anger you'll say something you're
gonna regret just step back and take a
moment to regain control over your
emotions and if you're on the other side
of that argument consider giving that
person an opportunity to do that instead
of pushing it sometimes too
so it's our nature but it seems like an
excuse you say oh I'm angry and you got
to forget about it but it hurts so bad
what you said
for Osama to win me back it would take
an act of God
you know I think this is the first time
I've seen someone decide to walk away at
the right time on this show aka before
all hell breaks loose and yeah I get
that this seemingly wasn't the best
relationship for Debbie in the first
place but like Alexandra says at least
she came to her senses sooner than
others you'll never believe in my love I
did Believe in Your Love what do you
think made me come all the way to
Morocco and move because of your love I
believed in you I love it you but you
didn't accept this oh he is BS in her
and it's kind of getting under my skin
y'all know I always try to be fair and
as I was writing this week's episode I
was like dang it seems as if I am
totally team Debbie but I mean can you
blame me look at what's happening I will
say this though to balance things out a
bit it's something I had to remind
myself of Usama is 24.
yeah his age does not excuse his
behavior there are some mature 24 year
olds but it's something to take into
consideration he still has a lot of
learning to do and hopefully some
character development we've changed
because I know you deeply I know she's
the change oh no he didn't try to flip
the script well I think
stronger and you don't like Debbie to be
stronger the future is dying here so how
you want to live in a vocal no I'm
staying here you will lose your money
I've got money my money is my business
facts I was willing to build the
foundation for us I know my country
you don't know squat man you don't know
squat
talk to the hand because
I don't think I've ever seen a grown
woman say talk to the hand and mean it
definitely marches to the beat of Her
Own Drum and I love it and speaking of
marching she's about to March off on
Usama Debbie tells him she's moving on
without him and makes her exit I wanted
to believe the best in him
and even though I wanted him to be my
hero
my prince charming it is a bait and
switch of the most cruel kind
to outwardly become someone's hero but
inwardly becoming someone's worst
nightmare come true
well I'm still trying to wrap my head
around everything she just said
hmm well what I did grasp is that she
wanted Usama to be her hero but I think
Debbie is learning that
she's the actual hero in her story when
I spoke to her in March she credited
Usama for helping her get back into the
world after locking herself away for
years how did you come out of that dark
space that 12 years of Exile how did you
re-emerge
the Debbie you are today well it was due
to Osama his kindness and you know what
every person
is sometimes starving for that empathy
Osama offered some empathy and kindness
which makes me think maybe that's all
she needed from him sometimes people
come into your life to get you to a
certain point not to be there forever
thanks to Osama entering her life Debbie
was able to be introduced to the world
on this show I'm just a people person
but I've been shut up for 12 years not
and so now it's his phone and who knows
what bright future she has ahead that
woman is entertaining and uplifting
Romans 12 21 do not let yourself be
conquered by evil but keep conquering
evil with good I'm just trying to do and
make a difference you know Jane says I
want Debbie to be the next Bachelorette
you know there's some talks of the
bachelor and bachelorette franchise
coming out with a show for more mature
people Debbie would be in her princess
Mo 24 7. I could see it now I'm packing
my bags and leaving Morocco and it's
just a
uh
a mixture of all kinds of emotions
I'm angry at myself I'm angry at Osama
but how can you get angry at someone
that never was Debbie says Usama through
their three-year relationship away yes
three years but she believes somehow
some way she'll recover from this that
you've got a wiser Debbie now
so you know I'll have to work on myself
to be able to trust again
but I can do that I'm tough old broad I
really am whatever I'm just going back
like yes I can that is the attitude
speak it I'm ready to rock and roll
Debbie struts as she makes her way to
the cab that's taking her to the airport
okay gentle man the driver isn't gonna
help her put her suitcase in the van
even when they get to the airport Debbie
puts her hand out looking for assistance
getting out the car and she got nothing
she pulled her hand back in real smooth
though I don't know maybe it's a
cultural thing over there or maybe not
he did help put the suitcases on the
cart though I'll give them that Debbie
tells the camera that it's time for her
to snap back to reality and I need to
pay attention and listen and wake up
from this fantasy and once she grabs her
suitcases she eagerly heads toward those
airport doors this experience was like
sticking your finger in a light socket
and getting electrocuted
Debbie is running for her life literally
and I'm here for
Osama taught me some very very hard
lessons after 12 years of isolating
myself
to protect myself because I couldn't
trust a man with my emotions now it's
like okay I've been burnt by the worst
of them so I will never communicate with
Osama again and I've got to be smarter
and wiser I'm not going to Hole up even
though it looks pretty good to hold up
after this Debbie goes on to say that
she's not allowing Usama to have power
over her anymore I'm not going to let
the bad guy win
Osama don't win in this Debbie's gonna
win in this
oh
go Debbie I'm proud of her she admitted
to making some bad decisions but she's
not gonna let it Define her she
acknowledged what she learned from the
experience
and now she's moving on I know her kids
are super happy she's coming home
all right 90 day fans fam the countdown
is on we have one more episode before
this Halal I will see you next time
foreign